thank you very much appreciate it a lot
of tremendous things are happening the
number of new positive cases continue to
decline nationwide recent hot spots
appear to be stabilizing the hot spot
sir in some cases very interesting
what's going on and they're going down
they're going in the right direction
cases in the Boston area are now
declining the Chicago curve appears to a
flattened which is terrific in Detroit
as past its peak these trends
demonstrate that our aggressive strategy
to battle the virus is working and that
more states will soon be in a position
to gradually and safely reopen that's
very exciting was very exciting even
today watching and seeing what's
happening and people are getting ready
and they're all excited I do want to
mention man who's done a very good job
for us dr. Robert Redfield was totally
misquoted in the media on a statement
about the fall season and the virus
totally misquoted I spoke to him he said
it was ridiculous he was talking about
the flu and Corona coming together at
the same time and Corona could be just
some little flare-ups that we'll take
care of we're gonna knock it out we'll
knock it out fast but that's what he was
referring to coming together at the same
time and I think rather than waiting I'd
ask dr. Redfield to come up say a couple
of words just to straighten that out
because he didn't say it was a big big
explosion the headline in the Washington
Post was totally inaccurate the
statement wasn't bad in the post but the
headline was ridiculous which is as I
say that's fake news and CNN is fake
news like crazy and they had just
totally the wrong story which they knew
they were asked to change it and they
wouldn't do that and it was false so
I'll ask dr. Redfield who is you know
real professional to come up and explain
please thank you
Thank You mr. president
and really do think it's important to
clarify this as we build the confidence
of the American people when I commented
yesterday that there was a possibility
of the fall/winter next fall in winter
it could be more difficult if achill
more complicated when we had to
respiratory illness is circulated at the
same time influenza and the chrono virus
19 but I think it's really important to
emphasize what I didn't say I didn't say
that this was gonna be worse I said it
was gonna be more complicated because
we'll have flu and corona virus
circulating at the same time I want to
emphasize that we continue to build the
nation's public health infrastructure to
ensure that we have the capacity to stay
in the containment mode those of you who
heard me talk before I've told you that
in January in February up to February 27
28 this nation had 14 cases we were in
the containment mode and then
unfortunately the virus overwhelmed
where we got into scream and mitigation
we are building that public health
capacity now to make sure that we stay
in the containment mode for the upcoming
fall and winter season so we will not
need to resort to the kind of mitigation
that we had to this spring I have
confidence that our public health
response of early case recognition that
we've talked about isolation and contact
tracing combined with our plans for
increased surveillance particularly for
the most vulnerable will be an effective
a public health strategy so our nation
will be able to maintain itself in the
containment mode again that will be
supported by the American public's
continued cooperation obviously in the
areas of personal hygiene and that the
types of social distancing strategies
that may be appropriate the key to my
comments and the reason that I really
wanted to stress them was to appeal to
the American public to embrace the flu
vaccine with confidence
one of the greatest tools we have as we
go through the fall winter season that
we're into is to get the American public
to embrace the influenza vaccine and
thereby minimize the impact of flu to be
the Co respiratory disease that we
confront thank you very much he was
misquoted totally misquoted he said they
could come together they didn't talk
about that and his whole purpose in
making the statement was to get a flu
shot so that next fall we don't have
such a big season of flu and we possibly
won't but as you said this it's possible
if the corona even comes back and he
doesn't know that it's going to a
neither do i we spoke at great length
and I think the doctor will speak of
you'd like to continue but we may have
some embers and we're going to put them
out of Corona but we may have a big flu
season but that's different flu is very
different from corona Redfield The
Washington Post which you did the
interview with them and they quoted you
as saying there's a possibility that the
assault of the virus on our nation next
to winter will actually be much even
more difficult than the one we just went
through and when I've said this to
others they've kind of put their head
mark they don't understand what I mean
we're going to have the flu epidemic and
the corona virus epidemic at the same
time is that what you said to the
Washington Post yeah that's what I was
trying to say to you just a minute ago
that the issue that I was talking about
about being more difficult is that we're
gonna have two viruses circulate at the
same time this spring that we just went
through February we had a benefit of
having the flu season ended so we could
use all our flu surveillance systems to
say whoops this is corona virus we need
to focus next fall and and winter we are
gonna have two viruses circulating and
we're gonna have to distinguish between
witches flu and which is the corona
virus and so the comment that I made
it's more difficult doesn't mean it's be
more impossible doesn't mean it's gonna
be more as some people have said worse
it just means it's the more difficult
because we have to distinguish between
the two and what I was
wanting to do and what I want to do
again here is appeal to the American
public to recognize they can really help
like they did with mitigation which they
really helped I need them to help now to
best prepare us by getting the flu
vaccine and taking flew out of the
picture you were accurate
I'm accurately quoted in the Washington
Post as as difficult but the headline
the headline says CDC director warns
second wave of coronavirus is likely to
be even more devastating and isn't that
what he says not what he said but if you
have the two things I actually think
it's actually gonna be I think the
American public is gonna heed the
requests to relook at their vaccine
hesitancy the vaccine with confidence
for flu and I'm confident that the
public health infrastructure that we're
putting together now across this country
so that we can early case tight diagnose
isolate and contact trace as I say block
and tackle block and tackle that system
is going to be there and we're going to
be able to contain this virus
you weren't all like we talked about
this yesterday when you asked me this
question and someone I think used the
word devastating and I want to really
again emphasize to the American public
that when we first interacted with this
virus for the first time in the February
and March timeframe we didn't have an
understanding of its transmissibility
all of its symptoms we do now and I
think what we are building together in
that when we talk about the public
health infrastructure it is very much
working on the surveillance piece but I
think we also know the strength of the
American people and their ability to
immediately understand how to protect
themselves with not touching their face
making sure that they're washing their
hands but the other piece I want to just
talk about and we mentioned yesterday
also that we have the summer while we
have flu sir flu surveillance that we
can utilize in syndromic management that
we can utilize we have all of that time
to prepare clearly the testing algorithm
that you would need in a flu potentially
if kovat came back potentially and so we
are preparing for that potential right
now and I think we spoke to you all
about that and talked about how we're
not only preparing for today and
tomorrow
but we're preparing for six months from
now three months from now and making
sure that all of these pieces are in
place I think what dr. Redfield clearly
was asking for just like we asked for
every American to follow the guidelines
he's saying please add to that
guidelines getting your flu shot that we
put up the great thing is we'll be able
to find it earlier this time and I think
that's what we're talking about we'll
find those cases earlier so what dr.
Redfield said we would be able to stay
in containment phase and what we're also
hoping and we talked about this about
four or five weeks ago that we're hoping
that the flu infections also go down B
because people are much more aware of
respiratory illnesses and how to protect
themselves I want you to get your
vaccine but we also want to also protect
individuals from getting the flu because
of the vulnerability we know in certain
populations to flu and the and the
devastating outcomes to flu we could
prevent and decrease both of those
things so I think we are assured that
the CDC is putting in place today what
we are going to need in the fall so that
we can stay in containment
if potentially the virus comes back and
if it comes back though it won't be
coming back in the form that it was it
will be coming back in smaller doses
that we can contain but what the doctor
was saying when I spoke to him a great
length he was saying if it should come
back together now you have a flu and you
have the embers of Corona
but in my opinion from everything I've
seen it can never be like anything that
we witnessed right now what you say we
will not go so you could have some
embers of Corona and you can have a big
flu system and if they combined if they
come together if they come together it's
not great but we will not go through
what we went through for the last but
how can you say that you know it won't
come back in the same level that it has
today what it is estimated might not
come back at all Jeff it may not come
back at all he's talking about a worst
case scenario where you have a big flu
and you have some Corona and if it does
come back it's not going to come back
and I've spoken to ten different people
not gonna be like it was also we have
much better containment now before
nobody knew about it nobody knew
anything about it we understand it now
if we have pockets a little pocket here
then we're gonna have it put out it goes
out and it's going to go out fast we're
going to be watching for it but it's all
possible it's also possible it doesn't
come back at all
but I don't understand how you know it
won't come back on a big scale I didn't
say it's not I said if it does it's not
going to come back or anything near what
we went through but you could have a
mess where they come at the same time
and if they come at the same time the
flu is not the greatest thing in the
world Jeff it's not the greatest thing
either if they come at the same time you
have them both but if we have embers of
Corona coupled with the flu that's not
gonna be pleasant but it's not gonna be
what we've gone through in any way shape
or form yeah if you're don't think that
it's a comeback and the same scenario is
right now why are you still directing
that taxpayer dollars you spend an
emergency procurement of ventilators we
have to have them for other reasons
something else could come I mean we
didn't know about Corona now we know
about Corona but look at what happened
and now we did have the h1n1 swine flu
we had that we have other things that
have happened we had various forms of
flu but nothing like what we've had here
nothing at all like what we have had
here with the virus but something could
happen I think that the stockpiles we're
making hundreds of thousands of
ventilators right now nobody writes
about that you know at the one time all
they talked about was ventilators right
because you didn't think it was possible
for me to solve that problem and I
solved it and nobody can believe it I
just spoke to world leaders today who
desperately need ventilators they said
the job you've done and we're sending
500 to Mexico then another 500 to France
we're sending some to Spain we're
sending some to Italy we have them
they're being made by the thousands and
world leaders I spoke to Prime Minister
I mean I went through a lot of different
calls today I won't even tell you but I
went that I can give you a list if you
want but I went through a lot of calls
to a lot of leaders spoke with Pakistan
they would like to have some ventilators
we're gonna get him some ventilators but
they all said to be one thing it was
incredible that you sawed off the
ventilator problem cuz that was a big
problem the testing problem we've done
more than any other nation in the world
go a step further
you added up the testing of every nation
in the world put them together we've
done substantially more than that
you people aren't satisfied so let's say
we had three hundred and fifty million
people in the United States right let's
say and if we gave every one of those
people a test ten times so we gave 350
people a test ten times the fake news
media would say where's the 11th time he
didn't do his job Trump didn't to his
job because you have a lot of bad
reporting out there it's very sad and
it's so bad it's not true they wanna get
one of the leaders of the bedroom okay
let's get on to another subject I wanted
that to be I wanted that to be cleared
up if you want we can get onto it later
but I want the vice president to speak
but you ought to get the news accurately
you oughta write it if you if you take a
look at what you wrote about the
ventilators and when we became the king
of ventilators we're making different
factories all over ventilators by the
thousands in fact Mike got back from
Wisconsin first thing he did he called
up I said how's it going he said you're
not going to believe he just saw a plant
two factory where they're making
ventilators I think I can say the words
were unbelievable he said it was
unbelievable
when he saw the quality of the equipment
the the professionalism a tremendous
number of how many workers would you say
were they're about to production nobody
thought this could be done the fake news
was very unhappy that it was done but
you guys don't ask me about ventilators
anything who's unhappy than everybody
because you never mention it you never
mention it there's no storage what a
great job we've done with ventilates
we're now supplying ventilators all over
the world because no other country could
have done what we did and you should say
that's a great story instead you say
Trump was slow or slow
we were so fast plus we put the ban on
so much earlier when Nancy Pelosi as an
example you don't say this when she's
having her rally in San Francisco in
Chinatown in San Francisco nobody wants
to say that if we didn't and doctor foul
she said this if we didn't close our
country to China we would have been so
infected
nobody's ever seen when you saw the
chart and we were at the top of the list
in terms of success nobody wrote it I
said where is anybody going to use that
jerk nobody wrote it in terms of
mortality so that nobody wrote it
Germany and our country the most
successful in terms of mortality nobody
wrote it it would be great if you wrote
the truth but let's get on with it
because I want Mike to speak and then
we'll take some more questions
one the assumption you'd like to and I
think you probably will it's been
encouraging to watch States
begin to open up as and it really has
been it's a beautiful thing to see as
restrictions are lifted we must maintain
vigilance and continue practicing social
distancing I encourage governors to
follow a careful phased approach and I
want to remind all Americans to adhere
to our guidelines very important the
governors are going to adhere hopefully
or they're gonna do what they think is
best I want them to do what they think
is best but ideally they'll adhere wash
your hands avoid close physical contact
as much as possible and wear a face
covering when distancing is impractical
there were cases we flattened the curve
and really made tremendous progress but
we must guard against a dangerous
rebound we don't want to rebound that's
so important this is what we're just
talking about we don't want to rebound
the doctor doesn't want to rebound these
people definitely don't want to rebound
I don't think you want one do you have
you especially we don't want rebounds
after all this death death that we've
suffered not work I love you work I have
you at death that was unnecessary should
have never happened should have never
left that little area where it started
you know it and I know it and they know
it in our all-out war against the virus
we continue to make great strides on
testing famous testing doing more than
anybody else anywhere in the world
nothing funny about that John most of
the governors have never faced a
situation like this before
but we're helping them find unused
testing capacity within their states
tremendous testing capacity that the
governors in many cases didn't
there and additional capabilities are
coming online everyday we're coming up
with new equipment like the Abbott
Laboratories equipment on-site five
minutes great success everybody wants it
but you can only make so many of those
machines so we have many other forms of
testing we have many other machines that
do it very quickly and by the millions
by the millions our task force issued
its reopening guidelines earlier than
April 30th to give governor's the time
that they needed to develop testing
capability and capacity and customized
plans for their states which many of
them did we've had some governor's do a
fantastic job on testing and on a lot of
other things I spoke because you know
Governor Cuomo was here and we had a
great conversation on testing yesterday
and they're doing a really good job in
New York
we're working very closely with each of
the states to help them succeed I spoke
earlier today with governor Newsom
California and that was all about
testing that conversation he's been
scaling up really well really good job
then I agreed to help him get some of
the critical supplies that California
needs to make use of the tremendous
capacity that they found this is a
tremendous testing capacity and I'm
gonna do it very quickly he needs
certain things I'm what we're gonna get
that to him very quickly now could he
get it himself yes but I can get it
faster he understands that and he's done
a great job and we're gonna have it to
him we're gonna have a lot of it to him
over the next two days and we're gonna
beef it up the following week get him a
lot of additional he's done a really
terrific job in California some of the
governors have done a fantastic job
working with us I told the governor of
Georgia Brian Kemp that I disagree
strongly with his decision to open
certain facilities which are in
violation of the phase 1 guidelines for
the incredible people of Georgia they're
incredible people I love those people
they are great they've been strong
resolute
but at the same time he must do what he
thinks is right
I want him to do what he thinks is right
but I disagree with him on what he's
doing
but I want to let the governor's do now
if I see something totally egregious
totally out of line I'll do but I think
spas and beauty salons and tattoo
parlors and barber shops in phase one
we're gonna face two very soon it's just
too soon
I think it's too soon and I love the
people I love I love those people that
use all of those things the spas and the
beauty parlors and barber shops tattoo
parlors I love them but they can wait a
little bit longer just a little bit not
not much because safety has to
predominate we have to have that so I
told the governor very simply that I
disagree with this decision but he has
to do what he thinks is right I'm
excited to announce that in the coming
weeks the Air Force Thunderbirds are
incredible and the Navy Blue Angels
equally incredible will be performing
air shows over America's major cities
and some of the cities that aren't major
cities they're going to be doing a lot
of work a lot of very dangerous flying
it's dangerous you know think the odds
when you start going at massive speeds
and you're 18 inches away from each
other
that's dangerous work your son is a
great pilot and I don't know if he can
be could it be a could he be a
Thunderbird I don't I think I think he
probably could from what I hear I don't
know if I'd want him to be because it is
it's incredible what they were able to
do and to sacrifice our frontline what
we're doing is we're paying tribute to
our frontline healthcare workers
confronting kovat and it's really a
signal to all Americans to remain
vigilant during the outbreak this is a
tribute to them to our warriors because
they're equal warriors to those
incredible pilots that all of the
fighters that we have for the more
traditional fights that we win and we
win we want to win we always win
sometimes we don't want to win so we
just go to a standstill but that's
always that's not the way this country
works operation America's strong was the
idea of our great military men and women
the Thunderbirds and the Blue Angels
crews who wanted to show support to the
American medical workers who just like
military members in a time of war are
fiercely running forward the fight he's
going to be great I want to see those
shows I've seen them many times and I
can't get enough of them and when July
4th we'll be doing what we had at the
mall as you know we're gonna be doing it
last year was a tremendous success and I
would imagine we'll do it hopefully I
can use the term forever that was a
great success as you remember even
though it was pouring it was raining so
hard it was raining it I that was about
as hard as I've seen in a while but it
was an amazing success didn't bother the
the pilots didn't borrow the the
military didn't bother the the crews
that we had there so we're gonna be
doing that again on July 4th our great
military is operating at 100% during
this crisis and thousands of troops are
deployed alongside of civilians and the
covent hotspots as you know you see them
all over I spoke when I spoke with
Governor Cuomo and when I spoke to Gavin
Newsome and many of the other governors
they wanted to know if we could have
some military help with the medical and
we we gave it to them and in every case
they said fantastic I mean just
fantastic New York City mayor de Blasio
called me to say it was inspiring to
watch he was there when the military
came in he said it gave everybody spirit
when he saw the professionalism and the
spirit that they had they walked in and
they helped a lot of a lot of people
doctors nurses respiratory technicians
and professionals it was an incredible
thing but they all everybody that saw
them going to work said that was
something special so we're gonna have
some tremendous air shows all throughout
our country and that's an honor of
what we're all going through together
and the people that are helping us so
much and unfortunately the people who
have passed away from something that
should never have been allowed to happen
following around-the-clock negotiations
yesterday the Senate answered my call to
replenish the paycheck protection
program so that millions of additional
American workers can keep getting a
paycheck we just increased it by three
hundred and ten billion dollars I urge
the house to pass the bill without delay
in our first round of funding we
provided nearly three hundred and fifty
billion dollars and it went at record
speed to American workers and small
businesses and it's really been an
incredible incredible success I want to
thank the banks with the big banks the
little banks the commercial banks of all
kinds we had the community banks were
fantastic by the way
community banks and as you know this was
an interesting story in recent days I've
called for Harvard
that's Harvard University which has a 40
billion dollar endowment fund to return
the money that it was allocated under
the cares Act and I'm pleased to
announce that Harvard has announced
today that they will not accept the
funds nor will Stanford University or
many of the others that were involved
both on a university level also on a
company level some of the companies were
bigger than people had represented or
bigger than people had thought and
strong enough that they didn't need the
money so there's a certain amount of
money that we are not sending as soon as
I heard it I said stop fons and for the
most part I guess they stopped it Mike
right they stopped it but we're not
they're not accepting the money and
that's great and so I want to thank
Harvard
I want to thank Stanford and I want to
thank the other companies in a case it's
broken differently between colleges
and companies but I want to thank the
companies and the other great
universities and there's some great ones
the legislation passed by the Senate
yesterday also reserves 30 billion
dollars in loans for small financial
institutions that serve minority and
distressed communities are very
important we're determined to protect
our african-american Hispanic American
and minority workers who have been hit
so hard by this hidden enemy my
administration is pursuing a
comprehensive strategy to address the
full spectrum of needs in these
communities supporting both health and
economic revitalization first my
administration is committed to providing
the testing that is needed to fight the
virus in distressed communities and the
last month alone we have already sent
over 1.4 billion dollars to our nation's
13,000 community health care centers
think of that 13,000 to increase testing
and treatment in the underserved areas
we're also expanding access to
telehealth telehealth has become a big
deal you know I've been reading about it
for years and all of a sudden because of
this it's become a big a big thing
people can't leave their houses they
didn't want to leave the houses for
various reasons including they wanted to
follow the guidelines the legislation
passed by the Senate yesterday and I
want to thank everybody a great great
vote great it's as you know is a
unanimous vote how often do you see that
but the legislation passed by the Senate
yesterday includes an additional 25
billion dollars to further expand
testing and provides even more funding
for community health centers and various
forms of epidemics and pandemics and
we'll be working on that because you
know ask for a couple of your statements
and questions before we want to work on
that for the future we hope this doesn't
happen again for again ever but last
time was of this magnitude 1917 that's a
long time ago so we want to be prepared
and we are prepared and as I told you
we're building up hospital not only our
stockpile which is being enough greatly
being built up greatly but also hospital
stack stockpiles were
getting them what they need
we're working out costs arrangements
with them and we're getting them a lot
of the ventilators which are the hardest
thing for them to get both from a cost
standpoint and a technical standpoint at
the same time we're also supporting the
establishment of new testing sites
focused on these communities 40 sites
have launched so far and there are plans
to launch dozens more in the next three
weeks where we're coming up with testing
apparatus and testing plans that are
incredible when you look at the numbers
and some people are very very big on
testing big on testing but some people
are much less big than I am I will tell
you and they're professionals but we
want to have it so that nobody can talk
about few ways I wish we had more
testing nobody's done it like we've done
it and nobody will and we're getting
very much stronger we have incredible
professionals doing it so many different
tests of Nod evolved people are finding
it even hard to believe my
administration is working closely with
governor's to ensure that they have the
testing infrastructure in place to
reduce further spread of the virus if
they're so inclined to use the testing
apparatus including strategies for older
individuals low-income Americans
minorities and Native Americans as part
of the effort the White House Task Force
headed up by Mike who has done
incredible said every time I'll say to
anybody that wants to listen Mike Pence
has done an incredible job really an
incredible job thank you is providing
technical assistance to all 50 states
through what on one phone calls as they
develop and implement their plans in
addition my administration is committed
to restoring black and Hispanic
communities to full economic health they
want to be healthy economically and
physically and that's what we're doing
to that end today I'm directing the
White House opportunity and
revitalization Council led by secretary
ben Carson to focus its effort on
supporting underserved communities
impacted by the corona virus and so Ben
Carson is working on that with Mike and
myself and a lot of other people I'm
going to ask Tim Scott who was so
helpful with the opportunity zones it's
an economic answer to a lot of problems
and Tim Scott was fantastic and so I'm
gonna ask him to get involved with you
and sure he'll be willing to do it from
South Carolina I also asked the council
to identify what additional funding will
be required from Congress beyond what
has already been provided we're really
building ourselves a strong base and
we're building ourselves a wall that's
very different from the kind of walls
that you've been hearing me talking
about but it's nevertheless in many ways
performs the same function and hopefully
it's going to perform it equally as well
furthermore the council will seek input
from the private sector and community
leaders on how we can best support
minority and distressed communities as
president I'm absolutely determined to
deliver a great future for Americans of
every race religion color and Creed
before our nation was attacked by this
horrible enemy our african-american
Hispanic American citizens were
prospering like never before best
employment numbers ever not only African
American Asian American Hispanic
American every American we were breaking
records at every level with almost 160
million people employed we were never
even close to that number and we were
also breaking them economically highest
stock market numbers highest numbers of
every kind and I think we're gonna be
back there and I think it's going to be
much sooner rather than later and I
think well surpass those numbers
including our employment numbers but
I'll not rest until that prosperity has
been fully restored and again I really
believe that we're going to lift those
numbers higher than ever before and it
won't be as long as people might think a
lot of very smart people are looking at
that and they're betting you just have
to look at what's going on with the
stock market in order to protect our
great American worker
I've just signed an executive order
temporarily suspending immigration into
the United States this will ensure that
unemployed Americans of all backgrounds
will be first in line for jobs as our
economy reopens crucially it will also
preserve our health care resources for
American patients we have to take care
of our patients we have to take care of
our great American workers and that's
what we're doing so I've just signed it
just before coming into the room and
very important very important and as to
amending it or extending it that we can
do at the appropriate time but it's now
signed earlier today the first lady and
I planted a tree on the South Lawn of
the White House in recognition of the
50th annual Earth Day I was led to
announce that we will begin to reopen
our national parks and public lands we
want Americans to be able to satisfy and
be really safe we want them to satisfy
their family that safety is going to
happen and it will happen and maybe even
at a level like never before we've
learned so much but we want them to
enjoy these great national treasures as
we continue to take reasonable
precautions and hopefully it'll be just
reasonable my administration has
directed more than seven billion dollars
in federal funding to support the
development of treatments diagnostics
and therapies and that's something
doctors I hope you can really work on
it's something so so powerful and so
important the FDA the NIH and industry
leaders are establishing master clinical
trial protocols to test multiple
promising new drugs at the same time
when they're doing a lot of we do it a
lot of testing right now more than 1,600
locations across the country have signed
up to administer convalescent plasma to
patients and fusing them with antibodies
of those who have recovered and when
they recover I said it last time
practically the first thing they say is
I want to give my blood so that I can
help other people they want to give
their blood it's incredible they're
laying in bed they're still in pretty
weakened conditions and they say I want
to give my blood and that's happening
all the time isn't it
if you recovered from the corona virus I
ask you to consider contacting your
local blood or plasma donation center to
arrange a donation that could
potentially save many lives with love
for our nation and loyalty for our
fellow citizens we will safeguard our
families care for our neighbors heal the
sick protect our workers and build the
future for a country that is the
greatest country anywhere in the world
and we're only going to get greater
thank you very much Mike Pence please
Thank You mr. president
White House coronavirus task force met
today and despite the fact that there
have been more than eight hundred and
forty-three thousand Americans are
contracted the corona virus and we
grieve the loss of more than 47,000 of
our countrymen according to dr. Burks
and her team we continue to see
encouraging signs because the American
people have been putting into practice
the guidance that's been issued by the
president and this task force and
they've been taking to heart and the
guidance of state and local officials
mr. president as we learned today
we are continuing to see declines in all
the major metro areas around the country
that have been most impacted numbers
remain low and steady on the west coast
in Washington State and in California
the New York metro area in New Jersey
Connecticut all appear to be past their
peak and as because our scientists may
reflect in a few moments we also are
seeing the positive rate going down
which is actually even as encouraging as
the declining cases the Detroit metro
area appears to be past its peak Seattle
metro area as I mentioned remain stable
New Orleans metro area is the most
stable of all the large Metro outbreaks
we also are continuing to see a
stabilization and even declines in in
Houston and Atlanta and Nashville and
Baltimore and Indianapolis and elsewhere
this is a tribute to the American people
to the fact that the American people
have taken to heart the guidelines the
social distancing the personal hygiene
the the recommendation that you use the
drive-thru at a restaurant rather than
going in a restaurant and avoiding
groups of more than ten the president's
behalf on behalf of our entire White
House coronavirus Task Force we just
want to urge all of the American people
to continue onward we all want to reopen
America and we want to reopen our states
and our communities as soon as it is
safe and responsible to do so but I want
to say to my countrymen the fastest way
to reopen America is to continue to do
what you've been doing it's the fastest
way as president Trump has said many
times to get our country working again
is to put the coronavirus in the past
and we are on our way to doing just that
you know for early on the president
called forth not only the full power of
the federal government but he called
forth the full weight of the American
economy and I had the privilege
yesterday to travel to Madison Wisconsin
and see American industry and American
workers at their very best and I want to
thank the GE health care team in
Wisconsin as well as the union machinist
that I spent time with all day yesterday
it was extraordinary and mr. president
in earlier this month you used the
defense production act to ensure that
supplies could flow to GE and General
Motors and Ford and other companies that
that were prepared to repurpose
manufacturing lines and hire new workers
to construct ventilators and if this
particular plant they literally have the
Union sat down the Machinists union sat
down and in less than one week
negotiated a new contract with GE
Healthcare that allowed them to begin to
bring in workers from around the country
they doubled they doubled their
their work line in one week they're
about to triple it they've been going 24
hours a day three shifts seven days a
week and then the president promised
that by harnessing the power of the
American economy we would have a hundred
thousand ventilators in a hundred days
but thanks to the ingenuity and the
hardworking Americans that I was with
yesterday and other companies we're
actually going to have a hundred and ten
thousand ventilators in a hundred days
they were all wearing t-shirts mr.
president I brought one back for you
that simply read union machinist save
lives and to that great team of GE
healthcare I want to just say all of
America is proud of you and grateful for
you we're also grateful to all of our
health care workers at every level and
all the work that they're doing and
we're proud that our National Guard and
our American military are at their side
as our task force learned today more
than 31,000 National Guard have been
stood up around the country and the
president in the last day extended
what's called Title 32 authorizations
for all National Guard personnel through
May 31 so we're going to continue to
partner with States as the National
Guard plays a vital role in testing and
in cleaning nursing homes and in
standing up States response
military personnel mr. president we have
more than 5500 active duty military
personnel including as of yesterday 964
medical professionals in the uniform of
the United States working in 17
hospitals in seven states around the
country we're also very proud of our
team at the VA and the VA has has
addressed its capacity issues it's not
seen cases among the veterans in its
facilities increase so they're deploying
teams to focus on nursing homes in
Massachusetts the VA personnel have
disinfected two different nursing homes
in New Jersey they literally taken over
two state nursing homes and deployed
ninety doctors and nurses and in Florida
were sending 16 teams to assist in
nursing home operations as the president
also mentioned in addition to what I saw
yesterday in Madison
Wisconsin we continue to we continue to
build our strategic national stockpile
it's growing again with ventilators on
nearly 11,000 in supply nine hundred and
one new ventilators will be added
transitioned in the near term and and
every American I think and can be
confident that should the need arise for
your family member
facing serious consequences from the
coronavirus to need that equipment to
help them breathe that equipment will be
there as we said yesterday in Wisconsin
and you said mr. president
I think it should be a great source of
comfort to every American that no
American who has required a ventilator
in the United States has been denied a
ventilator and that's a testament to our
health care workers a testament to every
American putting mitigation principles
into practice and it's a testament of
all these great companies speaking of
great companies American businesses are
stepping up it was on April 1st that I
traveled to a Walmart distribution
center and the president reached out to
the to the president and CEO of Walmart
to ask Walmart to get in the gowns
business and mr. president I'm glad to
report to you that we heard today at the
taskforce at Walmart is producing 8.4
million gowns and they will be delivered
into our commercial supply to health
care facilities around the country by
the end of June they're hardly alone
Honda is producing 500,000 face shields
New Balance is making a hundred thousand
masks a week in a very real sense the
American people have stepped up to make
the sacrifices and endure the hardship
that social distancing is required what
American businesses at every size and
every Amin's have come together to
respond to the president's call it
really has been a whole of America
approach and our message from the
president's White House coronavirus task
force is to tell the American people
it's working we're getting there we can
see light at the end of the tunnel we
can see the day that we can reopen and
put America back
work but it's going to take all of us
continuing to make the sacrifices
necessary to practice those disciplines
to get us to a place where we can reopen
safely and confidently with that mr.
president I'll call dr. pouchy up for
his reflections and thank you very much
mr. vice president so I'm gonna just
take off from where I was at this podium
a few days ago to kind of reiterate some
of the things that the Vice President
said but to kind of connect the dots
from where we were where we are now and
where I think we're going to be so we
remember a couple of weeks ago when we
talked about the fact that we were gonna
have a really bad week because the
deaths particularly driven by the
situation in New York we're gonna get
worse and worse but yet as that was
happening we were starting to see some
turnaround some flattening and some
coming down as you've heard from dr.
Burks and we'll likely hear more that
that is continuing so what has happened
is that the mitigation that we put in
with the first 15 days and then the 30
day mitigation program of physical
distancing worked so it got us to where
we are today it is a successful formula
it is the basis for our being able to
say that we can now think seriously
about reopening America and for that
reason we put together a carefully
thought-out and I believe well
delineated and described program for
opening up America again and you know
what it is it's the guidelines that we
announced a few days ago
those very guidelines are based on a
version of the successful formula that
got us to where we are so what I'm
trying to say is that the program is not
one that is going to be turn the lights
on in America we've finished we're not
we have to proceed in a very careful
measured way and if you look at the
guidelines they are careful
and they are measured there are certain
checkpoints before you can even think
about going into a phase one and then
things relax a little as you go into
Phase two and relax a little and you go
into Phase three now we live in a big
country and it's heterogeneous and there
are different dynamics of outbreaks in
different parts of the country so the
speed with which one can go from one to
another at the point at which you can
even begin to think about the phase is
gonna different so the one thing that I
know the urge we all have to get out
there and get it over with let's get
back to normal for a lot of good reasons
because there's a lot of suffering
economic and otherwise in this country
because of that but again as I've
pleaded early on weeks ago I plead with
the American public with the governor's
with the mayor's for the people with
responsibility although I no one has the
need to leapfrog over things don't do
that do it in a measured way this is a
successful formula the problem is if we
don't do that there is a likelihood that
we'll have a rebound and the one way not
to reopen the economy is to have a
rebound that we can't take care of so
please again let me just close by
pleading with the American public in
general and those who are responsible
leaders to carefully consider how we get
back to normal
what do you see for the fall is it gonna
be embers or possibly no return of the
virus at all you know as I've said
before here when you look at an outbreak
it's to dynamic forces opposing each
other if you leave the virus to its own
devices it will take off if you do
nothing to stop it if you put into place
the kinds of things that we talked about
first containment and then hopefully you
never get to mitigation but containment
is important those two forces are gonna
determine whether you're gonna have a
big outbreak so what dr. Redfield was
saying first of all is that we will have
corona virus in the fall I am convinced
of that because of the degree of
transmissibility that has the global
nature what happens with that will
depend on how we're able to contain it
when it occurs and what we're saying is
that in the fall we will be much much
better prepared to do the kind of
containment compared to what happened to
us this winter now the complicating
issue is that unlike the syndromic and
influenza like observances that we have
that you could pick it up by clinically
what's happening it's gonna get
complicated by a influenza season and I
believe that's what dr. Redfield was
saying that is gonna be complicated so
whether or not it's gonna be big or
small is gonna depend on our response
and and that's what I think people
sometimes have misunderstanding nobody
can predict what is gonna happen with an
outbreak but you can't predict how are
you gonna respond to it and that's
really very important so you would
caution against people thinking that
in the fall there's not going to be
coronavirus anymore we don't have to
worry about that no no it'll be spotty
and it will be a big problem I worry
about there will be coronavirus in the
fall if we do which we won't but let's
take an imaginary period we say okay for
our is forget about it we're not gonna
do anything about it
it will take off that's what viruses do
but that's not what's gonna happen we
are gonna respond to it to not allow it
to do that and moving forward even
without meeting the gating criteria well
well you know if I were advising the
governor I would tell him that he should
be careful and I would advise him not to
just turn the switch on and go because
there is a danger of a rebound and I
know there's that desire to move ahead
quickly that's a natural human nature
desire but going ahead and leap frogging
into phases where you should not be I
would advise him as a health official
and as a physician not to do that we
want American septage IRB's who on
Americans have the health care we want
to take care of our citizens first we
have to and it's a very powerful order
it's for 60 days at the end of 60 days
or maybe even during 60 days I'll extend
it or not and maybe change it I modify
it yes trying to get it and we're
talking about people and also by the way
people that are coming in illegally now
as you know because you've seen the
numbers our border our southern border
is very very tight hasn't been this
tight in years it's being helped by a
hundred and sixty more than that miles
of wall that are going up I'm trying to
get to 450 by the end of the year 450
miles and we'll have 530 miles
early next year and that's really great
it's fully funded we have all the funds
and the Army Corps of Engineers is doing
a fantastic job same people that did you
have it Center as you know they're doing
a fantastic job so our southern border
is very very tight for good reason a
very good reason we're also being helped
by 27,000 very good soldiers from Mexico
and I want to thank the President of
Mexico he's been terrific in many ways
including on what we're doing with kovat
and as you know we have a very good
trade arrangement with Mexico now which
we didn't have before so I want to thank
the President of Mexico in particular
for the 27,000 soldiers they're doing
for help you want to protect our
healthcare workers and that's one of the
other reasons we're doing this yes young
mr. Preston wouldn't ask you about Rick
right he's the head of the federal
agency in charge of getting a vaccine
out to two Americans once it's ready he
says he has been pushed out of his job
because he raised questions about
hydroxychloroquine and some of your
directives on that was he pushed out of
that I've never heard of him you just
mentioned the name I never heard of them
when did this happen this happened today
the guy says he was pushed out of a job
maybe was maybe wasn't I didn't have to
hear the other side I don't know who he
is you said by fourth of July you expect
people will be on the national ball and
what we're having a celebration right
okay last year given what the doctors
are just saying you know coronavirus is
still gonna be out there it might not be
as bad as it is now but it's suddenly
circulating if that is that gonna be
safe how many people probably have 25%
of what we had last year last year as
you know was maxed maxed out I saw a
magnificent picture of dr. Martin Luther
King and I saw a magnificent picture of
our event last year and both of them
were maxed out it was beautiful to see
beautiful very similar this year most
likely we'll be standing six feet apart
we'll have to do that in a very very
interesting way and maybe we'll even do
it greater so we'll leave a little extra
distance but if we do that would
certainly do that I don't see maybe the
purpose that we can't do that we have to
have people thousands we had tens of
thousands most of you were there tens of
thousands of people as she was
incredible and it was to an extent an
air show of all the different aircraft
flying over we even had Air Force one
flying over so ideally it would be
wonderful if we could actually have it
as it was last year but and eventually
will we will have that I think it's
important to know eventually we are
going to have that your stadiums are
going to be the way they've been for the
last hundred years I know but your
stadiums as an example sports going to
be the way they used to be I mean I told
one of the owners he said do you think I
should take out seats I said no you
shouldn't take care of seats we're gonna
have it the way it was we're going to be
back this virus will eventually begun
and if it should show up in the fall
we're gonna put it out very fast we have
great people we're going to put it out
very fast because we've learned a lot
we've learned a lot about how to deal
with us and we'll put it out very fast
we talked a lot about testing capacity
the governor's agree that that exists
but it was very different from testing
implementation and they are still
begging for you to use your full
authority to help them get reagents and
other things as you would like to say
what do you have to lose by helping them
do that becoming the king of testing and
let me just say we are the king of
testing already there's no country in
the world that's done more not even not
even 20% of the population has been
tested is that good and I just said
there's no country in the world that's
done more and we have tests that have
already come out that are going to be
introduced very shortly that will do it
more my problem is this it's a it's very
much of a media trap whether we did the
2 percent 5 percent 50 percent to 100
percent it'll never be enough no matter
what now let the with the expertise and
with what we did because of our
expertise and tremendous talent at
manufacturing what we did with the
ventilators that wasn't a trap because
we got them done shockingly to everybody
because of the incredible talent like
Mike Pence saw yesterday in Wisconsin
but we have numerous of those sites all
over the country doing the same thing so
that when the governors were complaining
some of the governor's I must say and it
was very much along party lines for the
most part but when the except for one
when the governors were complaining we
said no no how many do you need we need
50 we need a hundred one governor asked
for many many many thousands and it
turned out they didn't need that and
that's good we got them and nobody that
needed a ventilator you know this and we
went through this with the governor's
that needed a ventilator didn't get a
ventilator that was an incredible
achievement we're testing it's a little
different it's much easier than rental
eyes it's like 2%
but for instance the swabs are coming in
by the millions they're coming in
literally coming in by the millions
totally ordered we wanted the highest
quality we could have gotten a much
lesser quality we didn't want to do that
we got the highest quality but testing
it's like no matter how well you do you
can always say more with the
ventilations either have them or they
don't in fact we went to one meeting who
wants the ventilator one governor's one
governor said we'd like 25 25 you got
him who else nobody spoke up that was
four weeks ago so that was great the
problem with the testing is and I said
if we test if we test it 350 million
people you'll say don't we want them to
have a second test or a third test or a
fourth test not everybody believes as
strongly as some people in testing some
people want to do testing because they
think it's impossible for us to fulfill
that goal that's easy compared to
ventilators as I've said but we have a
tremendous testing capability better
than anybody in the world right now and
every day it's growing and it's growing
very substantially these doctors are
very talented people they've seen
testing all their lives they've never
seen anything like we've been able to do
so we're gonna give everybody what they
want with the testing but again testing
and I've said it from the beginning the
actual test has to be administered
locally you can't do from Washington or
faraway locations federal testing nearly
as well as you can will you have a
governor he has mayors and they have
representatives and and they know the
back of a Walmart put it in the parking
lot in the back of all mine or put it in
a certain location in different states
they're doing it beautifully it's
working beautifully the relationship I
have with the governor's and Mike has
and we all have with the governor's I
would say other than one or two but even
then they don't complain they're not
complaining
so we're doing tremendous testing and
ultimately we're doing more testing I
think than probably any of the
governor's even want okay please
back on the immigration the oh can you
say is it just for green cards for green
card holders so picking temporary
workers it's subject to change we have
some people coming in for instance
helping the farmers we want to have the
farmers take care of they've been coming
for years and years and they're helping
our farmers and they've they've been
coming in for years we don't want to do
you know the border has been turned off
a number of times over the years and you
know what happened
our farmers all went out of business
they were out of business they couldn't
farm we're taking care of our farmers
nobody ever took care of farmers like I
take care of farmers including the 19
billion dollars that were dispersing to
farmers because of some very good things
that happened subject to change because
some of your advisers are saying there
could be a problem with it or subject
you know just might be modified it could
be modified next week in two weeks it
could be modified in two months no we
may modify as we go along but right now
we have a very powerful immigration ban
but it could be modified meaning made
tougher or made less tough we don't want
to hurt our businesses and we don't want
to hurt our farmers very important what
did he say to you when you said you
strongly disagreed with him and first
for gym owners and tattoo power artists
and barbers in Atlanta Georgia generally
when you advise them to listen to you
and not to there go look I'd like them
to listen to their governors all of
their governor's I have the right to do
if I wanted to clamp it down but I have
respect for our governor's they know
what they're doing I think and as you
know Brian Kemp governor of Georgia I've
worked very hard for his election he he
beat their superstar he beat the
superstar of their party I think you can
say I helped a lot
Michelle Obama Barack Obama Oprah
Winfrey they all went in they campaigned
for him very very hard and he lost he
also was way down at a primary and they
ended up winning a primary after I came
out and endorsed him so a lot of good
things and there's a lot of good feeling
between myself and Brian Kemp I like him
a lot
I happened to disagree with him only in
time and timing I disagree
when you have spas beauty parlors and I
love these people I know the people from
spas and beauty parlors tattoo parlors
bikers for Trump a lot of tattoos I love
them I love these people and barber
shops these are great people but you
know what maybe you wait a little bit
longer till you get into a Phase two
so do I agree with him no but I respect
him and I will let him make his decision
would I do that no I'd keep him a little
longer I want to protect people's lives
but I'm gonna let him make his decision
but I told him I totally disagree okay
thanks mr. president
the vice president it is from Marx is
talking about the federal efforts that
have been undertaken as it relates to
nursing facilities and as you both know
they were just so incredibly hard-hit
just tragic
over 10,000 kovat 19 deaths so far the
industry says that they're struggling as
it relates to testing can you commit to
increasing testing at the nursing
facilities well we're doing it
automatically I mean that's almost
common sense but we're doing that order
man I mean you look at the state of
Washington that was our first glimpse of
it they got hit so horribly in that
nursing I would seem like everybody was
from a particular nursing home so we
knew immediately that was going to be a
problem and we're doing that a hundred
percent we're taking very special care
of our nursing homes and our seniors
other than me other than me nobody wants
to take care of me but other than me
we're taking care of our seniors no it's
it's just an enormous ly important
question and we want to thank the
American people who have been putting
off visits to their grandmothers and
grandfathers and moms and dads it's
tough
I'm going to be an Indiana
week and I'm not gonna go see my mom she
lives in her own home but people get it
that the risk of serious illness for a
healthy American of the coronavirus is
fairly low you'll either have flu-like
symptoms or no symptoms at all but as
we've said so many times this podium and
the American people get it a healthy
American could inadvertently convey the
coronavirus to a senior with an
underlying health condition and have the
kind of heartbreaking results that that
we've seen in nursing homes around the
country it's the reason why from early
on the president took decisive action to
raise the infectious disease standards
at every nursing home in America he
deployed all 8,000 of our inspectors
Senate Center for Medicare and Medicaid
Services to dedicate all of their time
to ensuring compliance with those new
higher standards we've spoken about
about about nursing home issues with
governor's around the country and
frankly their governors around the
country that have done remarkable work
with nursing homes
you mentioned governor Brian Kemp he
actually used the National Guard in
Georgia he deployed them to nursing
homes to do cleaning and a disinfect
areas of those nursing homes and it's
tremendous service but to your point
about testing if you look carefully at
the guidelines open up America again you
will see that in phase 1 the level of
testing that we contemplate is first
that we want to be able to test anyone
who has the symptoms that may be
coronavirus and be able to test them
quickly secondly we want to do the kind
of contact tracing and dr. Redfield and
his team are deploying CDC teams in
every state in America to be able to
find out everyone that that person has
been in contact with and tests them but
if you look right underneath that what
we're directing States to do is be
prepared to deploy testing resources
first and foremost in nursing homes and
term care facilities so that we can
monitor any potential outbreak of the
corona virus among the most vulnerable
population thanks to the leadership of
our Surgeon General as the president
announced today we're also going to be
deploying testing resources to
vulnerable communities to underserved
communities the CDC released new
preliminary data on the impact
particularly on African American
communities in in this country and it's
the reason why part of our phase 1
recommendation is that we deploy testing
resources into those communities that
are described by the doctors as socially
vulnerable and even as we speak we'll
announce next week that we're already in
the process of deploying testing and so
it's a good opportunity to remind every
American to be especially careful around
our seniors to heed the guidance about
avoiding visitations to protect the
health of those who are most vulnerable
but the American people can be assured
that from phase 1 forward all the way
through phase 3 and reopening we're
going to be helping to guide the states
to focus on the most vulnerable
beginning with our seniors with serious
underlying health conditions commercial
labs say that they need to buy new
diagnostic machines to be able to double
their testing capacity
your administration has said that
there's enough testing capacity to
double overnight how do you kind of
square that difference very easily they
can get new machines if they want but
even if they didn't we have tremendous
testing capability you take a look at
what's happening in California and New
York Governor Cuomo told us very
strongly he said wow we have a lot of
labs you know it's a research center of
the world they have tremendous in
California to long conversations they
have tremendous testing capability there
too now if they want to increase that
they can increase it but they have
plenty right now
you saw the maps the other day where we
put up the different sites in various
states and virtually all states are like
that how about you were the mess on
those maps from the other day on Monday
reporter for a local television station
in Miami sent me a question asking if it
was possible to get the information on
those maps distributed to the media so
that local TV stations and newspapers
can pick up that information
thank you for talking about testing and
testing capacity because we have been
talking about that for several weeks
because we could see and we did a full
inventory of every single state in every
single laboratory and I also appreciate
you talking about the implementation
piece of the testing capacity and it's
complicated so we have been we have a
team calling every lab and working
through the American Society of
microbiology as I mentioned before to
really work with every lab director to
see what the issues are in each
laboratory and I just want to thank
administrator Verma who really worked on
increasing the funding for this test and
uniquely doubling the funding for the
corona virus nucleic acid test from $50
to $100 to really address some of the
issues about laboratory technicians
because sometimes we think these tests
run themselves they don't they actually
need people
to help with the machine so we were
talking about purchasing more machines
we actually need to have additional
laboratory technicians to really be able
to work all of those machines and so
it's lab by lab state by state and
that's the dialogue that's going on now
to unlock the full potential of the
United States
maybe the testing it would not be needed
at this moment and maybe it is but we
want it also totally available in the
fall if it comes to an issue where we
have to distinguish between flu and
kovat night team so we're building
infrastructure and capacity not only for
today but for tomorrow and really
showing a new way to really deal with
pandemics and bring testing to scale
because the country has never had to do
this before I mean if you look at some
of the other countries there they're
struggling with some of the issues from
PPE to testing and so this is a
universal issue but we're working on it
as a collective to really have a very
innovated and integrated way to approach
testing and then I will ask the
companies because obviously it's
proprietary where every single machine
is and you know if you have that machine
and five others maybe you don't want to
know let that person know you have five
others it's kind of like Coke and Pepsi
so I think we're working very
deliberately to really be able to share
those maps the governor's I can tell you
that the all of the state local
governments state governors and the
mayor's have those maps and the
addresses and the type of machine for
every single laboratory in their
jurisdiction so that they do governor's
we're not aware that those laboratories
were available
the state of California is now partially
broken with CDC restrictions on who
would get guidance on who should get
testing because they want to test people
without any symptoms at all in high-risk
environments like a nursing home do you
agree with this
Natalie do we agree with it it was in
our guidelines that was fundamental to
our guidelines and I think we were the
first group that said testing
asymptomatic s' will be key we've always
said that we think that's a significant
contribution to infections and we went
to the places where we thought it was
most critical to find cases the earliest
and so that is where we have a state's
in the guidelines to start with nursing
home indigenous peoples and people in
underserved areas and cities to really
ensure that we're monitoring for any
type because we know the asymptomatic
piece may be the tip of the iceberg in
fact be the iceberg underneath the
surface and so if you're only seeing
cases maybe this but in parallel we're
working with states and local
governments to really define what that
population is by doing in collaboration
with States working with them together
to really and reinforce this antibody
testing but in a careful way where you
do to antibody testing to increase your
sensitivity and specificity into the 99
plus percent range because we think it's
really important that you have a very
high quality test but a high quality
test that you can really tell someone
that they've had this before and so
we're waiting to have those two tests
that we can do in in series to really
assure people but that is that was in
the guidelines from the very beginning
and we think it's fundamental both for
right now and going through the fall
because that will be our early alert if
any of the kovat virus reappears how
much more testing
see there's Thank You mr. president and
I just want to reiterate to everyone
that the task force in the
administration have a commitment to
protecting vulnerable people and that
includes in the area of testing we've
had the opportunity to talk to many
different groups and we hear that
testing is absolutely a concern and
we'll be giving you more details in the
coming days but I just want you to know
that we're building on the
public-private partnership that the
president rolled out with pharmacy and
retail companies like CVS Walgreens Rite
Aid Walmart and Kroger to accelerate
testing for more Americans and more
communities across the nation we're
going to be increasing access to testing
for under tested underserved and
minority communities and we're working
closely with partners and States to
establish sites in areas most in need of
increased access to testing we're using
data CDC provided data to locate sites
and counties that are under tested and
socially vulnerable especially with high
populations of black Hispanic rural and
Native Americans we're using the CDC's
vulnerability index as you heard about
heard about earlier to select sites this
measures the resilience of communities
when confronted by external stressors
along poor main themes socioeconomic
status household composition and
disability minority status and housing
type our goal our goal is to have about
2/3 of these initial sites located in
counties with moderate to high social
vulnerability and about a quarter of
these sites and counties with high
social vulnerability
so again I want communities that are
vulnerable to understand that we are
strategically and intentionally making
sure we're deploying testing in those
areas so that people can get identified
if they have symptoms can get identified
if they are asymptomatic and that we
will be able to deploy resources
appropriately
and I have to say our Surgeon General is
doing a great job thank you great job
really good oh yeah thank you
we talked about you put out a message
this morning making a rather big
announcement for our military when it
comes to Iranian Iranian aggression are
you going to change formally rules of
engagement for our US military hundred
percent we don't want their gunboats
surrounding our boats and traveling
around our boats and having a good time
we don't want them anywhere near our
boats and say you know the order I gave
I don't think I have to say it again but
I've given that order under the Obama
administration it was taking place all
the time under my administration I gave
this order early on and nothing happened
they were very nice there were no
problem but then I noticed yesterday
they did that in a much lighter form but
they did that again I said we're not
going to we're not going to stand for it
so if they do that that's putting our
ships at danger and our great crews and
sailors a danger in danger I'm not going
to let that happen and we will they'll
shoot them out of the water
that's a threat when they get that close
to our boat and they have guns they have
very substantial weapons on those boats
but we'll shoot him out of the water
thank you but possible I'd like to ask a
question to dr. bouchy and then a very
different one to you too dr. Falchi
today the CDC in the USDA said that the
first pets in America had tested
positive the krona buyers what does that
mean and what should the
know about cats pets - pets so that
question was asked before but I'll be
happy to answer it again
certainly animals pets can get infected
big cats in in zoos have been reported
to be infected with corona virus there's
no evidence that the virus is
transmitted from a pet to eat to a human
now obviously is that impossible
I mean biologically you know anything is
possible but there's no evidence
whatsoever that we've seen from an
epidemiological standpoint that pets can
be transmitted within the household so
it's not surprising I mean we when you
have viruses that can infect multiple
species isolating it from an animal
doesn't necessarily mean the animal is
transmitting it yeah well you know
that's the Lion of the news you know it
probably happened III don't know mr.
president but I would imagine that one
of the dudes one of the zookeepers
probably had an asymptomatic infection
took care of the animal gave him some
food touch them or whatever that's oh we
got it thank you if it's not my question
for you president Trump my question for
you is earlier in these briefings you
talked a lot about giving Americans hope
and you wanted to focus on that but I
now that the crisis seems to perhaps be
lessening I want to ask you about
accountability and of course really you
know millions of Americans became
familiar with you as the tough boss who
fired people for doing the poor job I
want to ask you about that two specific
things there's a report from Reuters
today that's the HHS secretary put a
former dog breeder in charge of
day-to-day coronavirus efforts to begin
with and also on Basel reuters reported
today that Alex is our the Secretary of
HHS package at former dog breeder that
was this most recently former job in
charge of day-to-day operations of the
coronavirus what's a second the second
one is on face masks taiwan has a bigger
population in europe state early on they
had universal very encasement
the governor's want to do that you know
we ordered I don't know if you know 500
million face masks we have hundreds of
millions right now and if people want to
wear them that's up to the governors if
the governors want that absolutely now
it's more appropriate in some states
obviously than others you have the big
plains and you have certain states where
it's much less necessary but no that's
up to the governors and we have that
very well covered I think face bracelets
but people are aware we have we have
hundreds of millions of face masks and
we have at least 500 million that's a
lot
we'll have them very shortly it was
almost overnight but less than a month
ago our Surgeon General said that I'm
quoting their quote not effective in
preventing the general public from
catching crewmen of iris I mean is
should there be accountability there and
also for pages yes secretary
well I don't know what anybody like to
speak about I don't like thank you first
just so you understand if somebody wants
to wear them I'm all for it I think
comments that we made when we came in to
face masks I think it's important when
we came out with the CDC guidance about
face masks or what we called face
coverings was in recognition of the
growing understanding of asymptomatic
infection or pre-symptomatic infection
was a recognition that we could use a
barrier and the reason you know and I
have mine when I am in public that right
here that I use you know that this
barrier in case I was in fact infected
if I didn't know is a barrier to prevent
me to protect you in case I am it
happened to be a symptomatically
infected there's very good data to show
that the ability of viral particles to
go through a barrier is substantially
dismissed
diminished and that's why we recommended
these face coverings I think if you go
back to and CDC came out with that
recommendation some people may think
intuitively it's to protect them from
getting infected no it was to protect
you
from potentially getting infected by me
when I go out in public
I actually appreciate you asking that
question because it's one that uh that
we've had to clarify several times and I
understand why the American public has
been confused over time as dr. Redfield
mentioned initially we said based on CDC
World Health Organization and most other
major public health organizations that
the public needed to know that these
masks were not effective were shown to
be effective in preventing you if you
were a mask from catching coronavirus
another important thing to remember if
the context of those statements was a
run on medical mask on n95 mask and our
health care workers were at risk what's
changed what's changed as we found out
that unlike past viruses that are spread
through the respiratory route a
significant proportion of coronavirus
cases can be traced back to asymptomatic
spread so this taskforce deliberated
this we've always told you that we will
look at the facts and we will give
people recommendations based on the best
available evidence at the time and once
we saw that a symptomatic spread we said
well mass still aren't effective and
from our from our point of view at
preventing you from catching corona
virus in a significant way but we've
always told people that they should wear
masks if they know they have symptoms to
prevent them from spreading to other
people well now that we know about 25 to
50 percent of people are spreading a
symptomatically we suggest that people
were cloth facial coverings to prevent
asymptomatic spread you wear your mask
to protect me I wear my mask and dr.
Redfield mentioned it I've got my mask
believe I have mine on me Bob I carry
mine around with me too
I wear my mask to protect you we're six
feet away which is why I'm not wearing
my mask to protect you now and we also
all have been tested so that's why I'm
not wearing mine now I'll put mine on if
you want me to sir but but again
important to know that if you're going
to wear a mask it's not a substitute for
social distancing still social
distancing is the number one thing you
can do number two it's important to know
that you should practice good hand
hygiene and not touch your face because
you still could touch a surface and
bring disease
your face and number three this is the
most important well it's it's just as
important please save the medical mask
the n95 for the healthcare workers
because the cloth facial coverings are
effective as far as we know right now
based on the best available evidence at
preventing you from spreading disease to
other people so no inconsistency there
it's just the recommendation changed
because the information changed and
that's what you want from your public
health leaders no argument made that you
knew about a systemic transmission at
the time that you said that in that you
were essentially misleading the public
the honest answer to you is no we did
not that was a recommendation of the
World Health Organization and the CDC
and we gave you the best information we
could at the time so I actually a little
bit revenge that implication because I
work hard to try to protect the American
people and we are always going to give
the American people the best information
we have available at the time and we
don't we're humble enough to say look if
we don't know we're gonna change we're
gonna change our recommend just a
wiseguy question that's Oh mr. president
about lunch if the military satellite
buyer bond wanted to get responsive do
you see this in advancement of the
missile program do you mean the shot
they took well they say no okay they say
also so it was for television does
anybody really believe that they won't
have better television in Iran so they
say no we're watching the run very
closely very closely we know more about
Iran than they do right now we know more
than they do so we know all about it we
watched it we knew it was going up we
followed it very closely they say it was
for television yes very quickly are you
concerned that they see this as a
potential vulnerability
the United States they're like what does
military readiness the outbreak of the
Roosevelt the fact that you're consumed
with dealing with various navies I've
had outbreaks of Kovac look we're in 184
different different nations right now
180 for the kovat no we have a problem
on that just shows you how rapidly it
spreads it started off with two sailors
and then ten sailors and twenty and now
I hear it's five hundred and forty of
which ones died and a few were very sick
but most of them are back in you know in
great shape but you did we did lose one
and it attacked the lungs of that young
person and then we also had a number
that were quite sick but they're all
either better or getting better but most
of them are better for a long time all
right okay
as you know over the course of the past
few weeks there have been the closures
of several meat processing companies
across the country in several states is
this a concern to you are you going to
the increased testing in these
facilities itself the word of the
dusters yeah look at South Dakota how
well the governor's done there and all
of a sudden you have a big spike in one
location and she's got that very much
under control as you know but
nevertheless I was surprising and they
had a big one right near where you were
yesterday as I understand it and so yeah
we're concerned about that they're
closing one or two of the plants
actually is the food supply secure yes
totally secure it's in great shape
the Attorney General in the state of
Missouri
a locust against China
accusing it of lying and covering up
about the illusion of the virus we
support that and you call everything the
case I know about the case he filed a
case against China
I love Missouri as you know it's great
but I'm gonna take a look at it I
actually know about it very much I have
to take a look at I have not seen the
case in terms of reading it but I will
be doing though the National
investigation I have to take a look
we're doing investigations we're doing
gone around but I do want to see and
review that lawsuit I'm sure that won't
be the last one yeah I sent a follow-up
question for dr. Apache don't mind so
John had asked the president about Ric
right and he said he wasn't sure who
that was but I'm sure you're familiar
who he is since he was the head of Barda
so there's this concern or an accusation
he's raised that he was removed from his
job because he protested widespread use
of hydroxychloroquine are you familiar
with this situation and do you feel like
public health experts feel they are able
to speak publicly or to speak out in
opposition to your hands yeah so you
don't feel like there's any concern
among people at the NIH right now are in
the Public Health the NIH dr. bright and
knowing what his gifts are as one of the
country's leading
experts on vaccines all those gifts best
suited at NIH rather than Barda what's
he gonna be doing with you what is he
going to be doing at the NIH are his
gifts best suited to work rather than
again I don't really think I can come in
on somebody's relative gifts I mean he's
gonna be at the NIH and he's gonna be
responsible from what I hear again this
is what I've heard that he's going to be
responsible for the development of
Diagnostics which is very very important
the NIH is going to be involved in
trying to develop new generation
Diagnostics which we feel is going to be
very important for the future of being
able to facilitate the kinds of things
that now are sometimes problematic and
what you say he has great gifts or gifts
what do you know him no no but have you
reviewed a Matthew have you studied him
have you reported on him you said his
gifts his gifts I mean gifts I know a
lot of people they play baseball but
they can't hit 150 the days are you talk
about his great gifts go ahead please
thank you sir um I have two questions
one for myself and then one for a colony
of ours who cannot be here today because
of social distancing from where from
where I'm with USA Today first the
executive director of the National
Association of County said today that
the White House did not want to see
money for a local it's state and local
governments and the latest ovid
assistance package they just want to say
what what does it mean I'm sorry what
does it mean repeated say it a little
differently the executive director of
the National Association of counties
said today that the White House objected
to putting funding for state and local
governments into the
the latest common assistance in truth is
your Democrat so check it how could you
ask that question well everybody whoa
check it out you'll find I'll check it
out okay what's a nice way it's
questionable you know the numbers you
know the money we put into States local
governments everything else and they
have to be responsible for their own
finances but you check it out go ahead
what's the next lesson he said that you
felt like that this would something be a
disincentive for States to open their
economies is he correct about that how
would he know what I felt I never spoke
to a modern even though who is you don't
know who he is you yes his name is
Matthew change sir
okay it doesn't help me and it doesn't
help you okay mr. president
you're not gonna say oh he took
questions already okay right okay we're
good how many questions can you ask oh
we all have fun because we're talking
about something very important the main
thing is I think we're getting to a lot
of solutions we never want this to
happen again we never want this to
happen again what happened and if it
should come back in some form we want to
snuff it out very quickly before
anything can happen and I personally
hope it doesn't come back in the fall as
a combination of the flu or not as a
combination of the flu but I think we
learn a lot and you know some of these
questions are good some of them are
ridiculous frankly but some of them very
I think some of them are very important
questions very important you know when
you ask dr. Fauci about the right to
speak if I let him speak I'll let
anybody speak and we love him let's go
mr. president sir Senator McConnell said
today that he would prefer to see states
that have high public pensions
declare bankruptcy rather than taking on
more I heard he said I don't know I
don't know what he said I'll have to
call him and ask him well that's okay
I'm gonna have to look at it directly to
see I want to base it on fact and reason
I want to see what he said you know why
he said it and how he said it
I'd have to watch him say it but some of
the states are not doing well let's face
it and some are doing phenomenally well
a state where Mike was governor Indiana
I looked at their numbers they have it's
incredible what they're doing some
states are doing fantastically well Iowa
is doing great you have you have states
doing well and you have some states that
aren't doing well we know the ones I
don't have to mention the ones that
aren't doing well but you do have states
that are in trouble and certainly
they're coming back to talk to us we'll
see what happens are you concerned are
you concerned sir about the growing US
national debt as a result of these two
what we have juice do we have a choice
yeah I'm always concerned about
everything we had to fix this problem
this was we were attacked this was an
attack this wasn't just oh gee and this
wasn't the flu by the way you know they
like to say the flu nobody's ever seen
anything like this
19:17 was the last time we were attacked
we had the greatest economy in the
history of the world we had the greatest
economy better than China better than
any place they will tell you that I
dealt with him for a long time and they
will tell with the greatest economy we
built it in the last three years three
and a half years we built it and then
one day they came and they said you have
to close it I said you got to be these
people right here they said you have to
they came into my office into the Oval
Office and they said we have to close
the Academy I said let's explain this
explain this to me the greatest ever in
history and we had to close it now we're
gonna open it again and we're gonna be
just as strong or stronger but you have
to spend some money to get it back open
we saved our Airlines we just as you
know finished up with the airlines
we saved numerous companies that are
great companies that two months ago
we're having the best year they've ever
had
all of a sudden it totally shut out of
markets there was a great spirit today
you know the fact is some of the
governors are opening up their states
and I thought I feel and I don't know if
you folks go I feel it there was a great
spirited I don't know the stock market
was up today I guess it was up quite a
bit when I just walked out here and I
will say I feel much different today
than I did two or three days ago
and I think the world does we spoke to a
lot of leaders the world feels that
we're really leading a path of optimism
European Union's having a lot of
difficulty you know you take a look at
what's going on with the European Union
at seven tremendous difficulty but we're
gonna be back and we're gonna be back
stronger than ever we're gonna be at a
level I think that everybody is going to
be look and they do they look up to us
they want to know what are we doing what
are we doing with therapeutics what are
we doing with vaccines we're gonna have
those answers - we're gonna have them
just like we took care of ventilators
just like we're taking care of and
already as we said a hundred times we
had more testing than any nation in the
world we had more testing than all of
those nations put together that we
mentioned the other day all of them put
together and we're gonna be within two
weeks at a level that nobody's ever even
seen before they've never seen where we
are right now you don't have to build
new machines you don't have to build new
labs we already have them but some of
the labs are even upgrading to be able
to double and triple their capacity in
one case nowhere